[Musique]
il est 8h30 sur RMC et BFM TV bonjour
Jean-Marc Jancovici Jean-Marc Jancovici
vous êtes ingénieur membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat président du
chiffre Project vous êtes aussi l'auteur
de cette bande dessinée best-seller de
l'année le monde sans fin qui alerte sur
l'environnement je précise que vous êtes
arrivé légèrement en retard parce que
bien il pleut à Paris et que maintenant
ces moments là les transports en commun
dont on nous vendent les mérites le tram
que vous avez pris était en quelque
sorte embourbé Jean-Marc Jancovici hier
Elisabeth borne a déclaré je cite les
Français vont vivre mieux grâce à la
transition énergétique sauf qu'au moment
où on se parle les Français ils ont
quand même l'impression que la
transition énergétique ça veut dire
qu'ils vont avoir froid ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir qu'il trouve de
l'argent pour changer de voiture c'est à
dire qu'il va falloir qu'il trouve de
l'argent pour payer les travaux de
rénovation thermique est-ce que vraiment
ils vont vivre mieux ça dépend à quelle
horizon de temps on situe ce qui est sûr
c'est que quand on a un sujet qu'on n'a
pas anticipé et pour lequel on sait pas
organisé à l'avance en général c'est
plutôt moins bien que mieux après le le
discours d'Elisabeth borne il est de
façon assez standard d'expliquer que les
choses vont bien se passer parce que
c'est le mandat de n'importe quelle
politique d'expliquer quel problème sans
sous contrôle et que tout va bien se
passer alors ça c'est le politique et
vous vous êtes l'ingénieur et en général
vous êtes plutôt franc est-ce que ça va
bien se passer pour partir ça va mal se
passer mais ça on le sait depuis
longtemps changer un système énergétique
ça prend à domicile
l'énergie abondante en fait à la
structuré nos villes et la structurer
nos moyens de déplacement pour donner un
exemple on est passé de 2 millions de
véhicules particuliers après guerre à 40
millions aujourd'hui il est bien évident
qu'on a organisé nos vies en fonction de
ça et que baisser brutalement cette
quantité ça pose des problèmes on a
organisé la façon dont l'économie
fonctionne avec ça par exemple
l'essentiel des emplois aujourd'hui sont
dépendants de chaîne de valeur très
longue et de la mondialisation avec
moins d'énergie abondante on a moins de
mondialisation et c'est pareil c'est des
choses qui changent pas en une semaine
est-ce que les décisions qui ont été
prises vous semblent même si visiblement
elles sont prises un peu tard parle-t-on
alors notamment des annonces donc de
d'isabeth borne hier sur la neutralité
carbone qui est obtenu en 2050 avec la
sobriété énergétique avec une production
d'électricité décarbonée autour d'une
clé et d'une renouvelable enfin c'est
principalement ça les piliers et le
troisième pilier c'est le développement
de nouveaux vecteurs énergétiques comme
l'hydrogène décarbonée nous expliquer
tout ça alors la neutralité carbone en
2050 ça voudrait dire que en 2050 la
France n'aimait plus un gramme de CO2
pour fonctionner donc ça veut dire qu'on
a plus une seule voiture thermique ça
veut dire qu'on a plus une seule
chaudière à gaz plus une seule chaudière
à fioul ça veut dire dans les logements
ça veut dire que dans l'industrie on a
plus non plus on utilise ni gaz ni
charbon ni fuel pour faire fonctionner
l'industrie ça veut dire qu'on en a plus
non plus dans l'électricité donc et en
particulier en ce moment des centrales à
gaz il y en a qui tournent et ça veut
dire que dans l'agriculture non plus on
a plus de fuel dans les tracteurs etc
donc c'est ça que ça veut dire
c'est jouable alors ça dépend des
contreparties
si on accepte de diminuer la
consommation d'un facteur 10
probablement à consommation constante
probablement pas et la question est de
savoir où est-ce qu'on est curseur entre
les deux et qu'est-ce qu'on va arriver à
faire après il y a une voiture balai
qu'il faut bien garder en tête moi je ne
cesse de le répéter mais pour le moment
c'est complètement sous l'écran radar de
la quasi totalité de nos politiques
c'est que de toute façon les gisements
de pétrole de gaz et de charbon enfin
les mines de charbon c'est pas éternel
c'est épuisable parce qu'il faut des
dizaines de millions des centaines de
millions d'années pour faire des
combustibles fossiles et il faut
rappeler que depuis 2008 l'Europe étant
décrue énergétique subit donc même si on
voulait pas être sobre de toute façon on
aurait moins d'énergie fossiles à notre
disposition que vous nous dites ce matin
c'est de toute façon on n'a pas le choix
de volonté politique c'est une question
de finitude non on n'a pas le choix et
la seule la seule question pour la
volonté politique c'est comment est-ce
qu'on s'organise face à ça est-ce qu'on
l'anticipe est-ce qu'on leur dit
notamment alors il faut accompagner il
faut anticiper il faut s'organiser et en
fait ce qu'il faut d'une certaine
manière c'est que tant qu'on a encore de
énergie fossile il faut s'en occupe il
faut s'en servir pour refaire les
infrastructures qui permettront de
fonctionner sans énergie fossile c'est
ça qu'il faut faire en fait on doit
utiliser les énergies fossiles restantes
pour pouvoir ensuite s'en passer
exactement concrètement quand même quand
je vous écoute et que vous nous dites
bon bah ok c'est jouable enfin c'est
jouable au prix de la suppression de
beaucoup de choses qui
occupent notre quotidien ça ressemble
moins à vivre mieux qu'à du sang et les
larmes quand même à court terme alors ça
ressemble à vivre différemment et c'est
évident que à court terme il va y avoir
des efforts significats et même plus
tard en fait il va y avoir des efforts
significatifs à faire et la seule
question je le répète c'est est-ce que
on les suit totalement ou largement et
là pour le moment c'est plutôt la
direction qu'on prend parce qu'on
anticipe pas ou bien on s'organise de
telle sorte qu'on puisse s'en passer
plus facilement et à ce moment il faut
pas se faire d'illusions sur la façon
dont on s'organise on anticipe pas mais
enfin je reprends le discours d'isabeth
Borny ça donne le sentiment en tout cas
qu'elle anticipe non quand je dis on
anticipe pas c'est qu'on a pas anticipé
il y a une partie des choses aujourd'hui
il y a une partie anticiper trop tard
c'est pas anticipé en général il y a une
partie il y a une partie des choses
qu'on commence à faire aujourd'hui ça
fait 20 ans qu'on aurait dû commencer à
s'y mettre donc en fait on a on a on a
fait un refus d'obstacle là c'est très
avec la question de la dépendance la
dernière fois que je vous ai reçu
j'avais été très frappé par le fait que
vous retrouviez dans des archives le
fait qu'il y a déjà 10 ans vous allez
Retiers sur notre manière de nous mettre
dans les mains des Russes on était bien
loin de la guerre en Ukraine mais déjà
vous disiez attention nous sommes
extrêmement dépendants le sommes-nous
toujours quand on entend le gouvernement
qui dit ça y est c'est bon nos cubes de
gaz sont pleines nos réserves de gaz
sont pleines est-ce qu'on peut se dire
c'est bon on est sauvé c'est
probablement un peu plus compliqué que
ça avant la guerre en Ukraine les Russes
fournissaient environ 40% du gaz
européen
la question c'est si on se passe du gaz
rush faut ce qu'on trouve le gaz
ailleurs alors trouver le gaz ailleurs
ça veut dire qu'on le fait venir par
bateau de forme liquéfier plutôt que par
tuyau GNL le fameux GNL plutôt que par
tuyau hors de passer de l'un à l'autre
c'est très long parce les volumes sont
pas du tout les mêmes et par ailleurs il
faut trouver des États qui veulent bien
exporter des étapes producteurs qui
veulent bien exporter du gaz en quantité
suffisante indépendamment du prix en
quantité il se trouve qu'au chiffre
project nous allons présenter dans pas
longtemps un travail très détaillé que
nous avons fait sur la base de
l'ensemble des fins de la connaissance
de l'ensemble des gisements casiers dans
le monde et qui montre que la production
de gaz dans le monde devrait passer par
un pic en 2030 pour des raisons
géologiques pas pour des raisons
climatiques pour des raisons géologiques
donc de toute façon se retourner vers
d'autres pays ça va durer un temps ça ne
sera qu'un pisé ça sera un pays ça
pourrait pas être éternel indépendamment
du fait que de toute façon si on veut
être neutre en 2050 il y aura plus de
gaz du tout à cet échec plus de gaz
fossile du tout à cette horizon de temps
soit il y en aura plus parce qu'il y en
aura plus soit il n'aura plus parce que
on s'interdira de l'utiliser alors le
plus probable c'est qu'il y en aura
toujours un peu mais moins
qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est clair avec cette
question évidemment qui est notamment
dans notre quotidien la question de la
voiture et de la mobilité qui reste un
des grands enjeux je voudrais écouter il
voudrait que vous écoutiez ce que Marine
Le Pen disait hier je l'interrogeais sur
la question du 110 km heure auquel elle
est opposée voilà sa réponse
on peut aussi s'arrêter de vivre de
respirer de d'avoir des voitures de on
peut retourner à la carrière à la
chevaux si on écoute d'ailleurs les
écologistes c'est à ça qu'on va revenir
mieux vaut en rire qu'en pleurer parce
que la réalité c'est que leur vision est
une vision de régression absolument
totale de la civilisation alors que
évidemment les solutions sont dans la
science le progrès c'est à dire qu'on va
trouver demain les solutions pour
pouvoir améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique comment on trouve le juste
équilibre comment on trouve le geste
équilibre entre cette cette moquerie
cette ironie sur le fait qu'en gros si
on écoute les écolos on arrête tout et
puis en même temps l'importance
d'innover de croire au progrès je vais
commencer par une remarque sur la
confusion des rôles qui est très
fréquente dans le discours des
politiques
entre le l'écologie en tant que
discipline c'est-à-dire que il y a des
gens qui font des constats sur l'état de
l'environnement et l'écologie en tant
que mouvement politique vous vous êtes
dans la première catégorie beaucoup de
gens sont dans la première catégorie
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les deux sont
pas les mêmes donc il faut bien voir de
quoi on parle la deuxième comme on dit
les écolos en général on parle plutôt
soit des politiques soit des militants
oui mais on parle souvent des militants
qui invoquent les scientifiques et quand
les militants invoquent les
scientifiques des fois ils les invoquent
bien des fois ils invoque mal d'accord
donc il faut essayer de revenir en fait
alors madame Le Pen n'échappera pas plus
que les autres au fait que les
combustibles fossiles sont épuisables
donc même si on ne veut pas je le je le
redis de toute façon il va falloir faire
avec moins de combustible fossiles en ce
qui concerne le 110 sur autoroute il y a
plein de pays étrangers qui sont déjà à
des limitations de vitesse de cet ordre
j'ai pas l'impression que les gens s'y
suicident j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils
soient extrêmement malheureux donc je ne
pense pas que ce soit majeur vous
comprenez que le gouvernement Élisabeth
borne était invité à répondre à cette
question lundi soir sur BFM TV elle
refuse de passer du 130 au 110 km/h sans
doute aussi par crainte d'une forme de
colère comme il y avait eu quand on est
passé du 90 au 80 km/h et vous vous
dites cette colère n'aurait pas lieu
pourtant alors je pense que ça tout
dépend de la pédagogie du problème je
pense les gens sont pas complètement
idiots et si on leur dit de toute façon
il va falloir faire avec moins de
pétrole est-ce que vous préférez qu'il y
en ait un peu pour tout le monde et on
roule à 110 ou que tout le monde ceux
qui peuvent qui ont les moyens roulent à
130 et les autres ils roulent pas du
tout qu'est-ce que vous préférez ça
devient un problème ça dit ça devient un
problème de de d'inégalités des
ressources d'inégalités des richesses
évidemment que ça devient un problème
social c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où ceux qui peuvent consomment
20% de carburant de plus quand il roule
bah ça on laisse moins pour les autres
si la quantité donnée si la quantité
totale est finie donc l'intérêt ce
serait de passer si je vous écoute bien
au 110 km/h évidemment pour tous
absolument et en plus ce serait moins
cher évidemment quand on fait le plein
disons et pas et par ailleurs plus
épisodique il y a quelque chose qui est
avéré c'est que plus vous freinez la
voiture plus vous favorisez le report
sur les modes alternatifs c'est-à-dire
que ça devient d'autant plus intéressant
enfin où les gens sont d'autant plus
motivés à prendre le train que vous leur
dites sur autoroute ça sera 110 au lieu
mais le train est très cher c'est-à-dire
que pour le coup si ça devient une
question d'économie le train le train en
France est cher alors ça dépend comment
vous comptez c'est toujours pareil si
vous comptez juste le coût marginal de
la voiture c'est-à-dire juste le plein
d'essence et le pH quand vous prenez
l'autoroute le train est plus cher si
vous comptez l'amortissement de la
voiture c'est le fait que vous devez
l'acheter que vous devez l'assurer etc
et que vous faites une comparaison entre
voiture et pas voiture à ce moment c'est
pas si évident que la région Occitanie
va mettre en place tous les déplacements
à 1 euro le premier weekend par mois
vous rappelez j'ai bien compris que vous
prenez toute la chaîne c'est à dire non
seulement l'achat du véhicule le plein
l'assurance les réparations fait d'aller
régulièrement chez le garagiste le
contrôle technique et il y a beaucoup de
gens qui achètent des voitures qui sont
dimensionnés pour le départ en vacances
et qui toute l'année servent entre la
moitié de leur capacités et on est tout
seul dedans mais est-ce que vous invitez
les responsables qui disent il faut
privilégier le train à baisser le prix
je le rappelle donc je depuis hier en
Occitanie le premier week-end par mois
le tous les déplacements c'est-à-dire
vraiment les transports en commun le
train tout est un euro
c'est une question il y a deux manières
si on veut avantager économiquement le
train par rapport à la voiture la
première manière c'est de monter le prix
de la voiture la deuxième manière c'est
de baisser le prix du train et comme il
n'y a pas de repas gratuit si on baisse
le tri le prix du train il faudra bien
que l'argent vienne de quelque part donc
est-ce que ça doit venir de nous impôts
est-ce que ça c'est un débat qu'il faut
avoir c'est à dire qu'à un moment faut
faire les comptes faut voir ce que ça
coûte et il faut regarder la solution
qu'on préfère il fait combien chez vous
chez moi dans mon logement
c'est devenu une question publique entre
17 et 19 ça dépend de la pièce ça se
balade entre 17 et 19 et quand vous avez
un peu plus froid vous allez dans les
dans les pièces à 19 quoi non c'est
parce que c'est il y a des il y a des
endroits quand on est plus près du
thermostat c'est un peu plus chaud je
veux dire mais est-ce que est-ce que
vous dites parce que je reviens toujours
à la question du vivre mieux grâce à la
transition énergétique est-ce que est-ce
que vraiment parce que ça fait quand
même trois mois qu'on dit aux Français
bah va falloir que vous baissiez le
chauffage il va falloir que vous mettiez
des cols rouler est-ce qu'on peut vivre
est-ce que c'est vraiment un argument
pour dire on va vivre mieux ou des
couettes vous savez pas se promener
partout dans l'appartement avec des
couettes non mais dans la pièce dans
laquelle on dort ça pose pas de problème
de rajouter une couette et de baisser la
température de quelques degrés donc vous
dites vous dans la chambre il fait
combien oh il doit à mon avis il fait
pas plus de 15
même un peu en dessous donc on vit donc
on peut reprendre la phrase d'isabeth
borne les Français vont vivre mieux
grâce à la transition énergétique vivre
au mieux avec pour le coup c'est pas
faux si vous alors si vous dormez dans
une chambre il fait zéro là vous allez
pas aimer mais par contre si vous dormez
dans une chambre il fait trop chaud en
général ça vous dormez mal je voudrais
qu'on parle de la situation justement de
l'électricité parce que l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles finalement on va
devoir tous baisser le chauffage
contrairement à ce que vous dites c'est
que vous avez toujours dit de toute
façon il va falloir qu'on baisse le
chauffage parce qu'on aura en effet en
tout cas pour l'instant pas suffisamment
de matériel enfin de d'énergie fossile
pour faire face là c'est aussi parce que
tout simplement on n'a pas assez de
centrale en service on a encore 26
réacteurs au moment où on se parle 26
réacteurs il faut quand même rappeler
que l'essentiel du chauffage dans ce
pays c'est du gaz et du fioul c'est pas
de c'est pas de l'électricité donc il y
a pas de sujet de réacteur à l'arrêt
pour tous les logos redites nous ça
parce que si moi je fais l'erreur
j'imagine que j'ai passé au gaz et au
fioul le problème c'est pas
l'approvisionnement électrique le
problème c'est l'approvisionnement en
gaz et en fioul la preuve qui vous le
disiez certes on nous dit que les
caisses les caisses enfin les réserves
de gaz sont pleines ça suffira ça suffit
pas pour passer l'hiver c'est à dire que
c'est avec les réserves de gaz que nous
avons si demain matin on nous coupe les
tuyaux et l'approvisionnement en continu
on passe pas l'hiver on passe pas
l'hiver Ah bah non il faut qu'on
continue à être approvisionné en même
temps que on tape dans les réserves les
réserves si tout d'un coup on ne devait
vivre que sur ses réserves donc on
appelle réserves stratégiques qui sont
les réserves françaises on passe combien
de temps alors je n'ai plus le chiffre
exact en tête mais enfin de mémoire le
stockage de gaz ça assure un quart ou un
tiers de ce qu'on va consommer pendant
l'hiver un quart ou un tiers de donc on
va devoir continuer à acheter du gaz
en apporter de manière extrêmement
claire et en fait le problème il est pas
de temps pour cet hiver si
l'approvisionnement en gaz à peu près le
même que celui qu'on a aujourd'hui il
est pour d'après je rappelle ma question
26 réacteurs à l'arrêt le calendrier de
retour à la normale de EDF étant suspens
ils ne sont pas capables de nous dire au
moment où on se parle quand ces
réacteurs seront remis en marche est-ce
que vous vous dites un la fermeture de
Fessenheim c'était peut-être une erreur
et deux est-ce que vous vous en savez
plus vous ingénieurs sur l'horizon
auquel on peut espérer que ces réacteurs
vont être remis en moi
ça veut pas dire que ça change
dramatiquement les ordres de grandeur
quand on a 26 réacteurs à l'arrêt si on
en avait 24 plutôt que 26 ça changerait
pas fondamentalement la chose après je
ne suis que je ne connais pas le
calendrier de remise de retour à la
normale il y a deux processus qui font
que il y a une partie significative du
parc qui n'est pas disponible le premier
ça a été les décalages du haut covid
parce que donc on est toujours dans
cette j'ai envie de dire dans les
conséquences du covid là-dessus et le
deuxième c'est la fameuse corrosion sous
contrainte c'est à dire qu'il y a eu des
défauts qui ont été trouvés sur des
circuits d'alimentation secours sur un
certain nombre de réacteurs et avec la
philosophie de sûreté que nous avons
actuellement on a considéré que ces
défauts justifiaient la mise à l'arrêt
de la centrale donc quoi qu'il arrive
l'horizon c'est pour ça il faut demander
la réponse quoi il y a des affaires n'a
pas la réponse ou est-ce que c'est parce
qu'il faut qu'on s'attende à ce que la
réponse soit très mauvaise je ne sais
pas il faut leur demander parce que dans
les raisons qui font que les réacteurs
ne viennent ne reviennent pas aussi
rapidement qu'espérer d'abord il y a eu
une grève il y a pas très longtemps
ensuite il peut y avoir problème à avoir
des compétences qui sont nécessaires sur
plein de réacteurs à la fois et puis on
en a pas assez pour intervenir sur tous
les réacteurs en parallèle et puis il
peut y avoir des problèmes de
disponibilité de pièces parce que c'est
des pièces spéciales qu'il faut il faut
avoir pour réparer les réacteurs les
fournisseurs peuvent éventuellement pas
être j'en sais rien donc en tout cas
c'est pas gagné j'ai pas le détail donc
c'est pas encore gagné et si et si on en
croit de toute façon vos projections
quoi qu'il arrive il va falloir
apprendre à se à merci davantage par
contre il y a quand même une différence
entre des réacteurs qu'on mettrait au
rebut et il faut apprendre
définitivement à se passer d'un de ces
réacteurs c'est différent de ils sont en
cours de réparation et ils finiront par
reprendre du service on ne sait pas
quand Jean marcovic merci d'être venu
donner toutes ces précisions à mon micro
sur RMC et BFM TV